the FAFSA deadline is nearing but
according to recent data only about 30
percent 36 percent of high school
seniors in our state have filled out the
form leaving millions of dollars in free
money behind in today's eight on your
side what you need to know
completing the free application for
federal student aid form known as FAFSA
allows you to be considered for
financial student aid colleges use this
information to determine your
eligibility well if the financial aid
office doesn't know that you need money
how in the world are you going to
receive your scholarships grants or
financial aid Mary Joe Terry of Y refi
says many families don't complete one
because they think their income is too
high but she says by filling one out you
may be alerted about work study programs
other grants you weren't aware of
colleges may use it to award private
scholarships from their own funds so
it's important to set aside time to
complete it go to studentaid.gov forward
slash FSA ID there is a verification
process that asks for a lot of personal
and financial information so you'll need
your parent to help you complete it
depending on which university you are
going to you may also need to go to a
second website you may also need to go
to collegeboard.org collegeboard.org is
actually a place where are they a lot of
Institutions manage their Scholarships
in Grants so definitely check with your
institution Terry says once you fill out
the FAFSA you'll be receiving a ton of
information she suggests you set up a
secondary email to keep track and
remember it is first come first served
don't procrastinate this is a deadline
process so whoever gets the grants and
scholarships first gets in line for the
grants and scholarships and you want to
make sure if you're starting in the fall
that you do have access to financial aid
if you need help reach out to the
admissions office and the financial aid
department the FAFSA form must be
submitted by 11 59 PM Central Time June
30th